we have breaking news from the White
House where President Trump has found a
replacement for fired FBI director James
Comey the president tweeted minutes ago
I will be nominating Christopher a ray a
man of impeccable credentials to be the
new director let's go right now to
Margaret Brennan she's at the White
House Margaret good morning what can you
tell us good morning Gail well this was
a very trumpian way to make this
announcement via Twitter to announce
Christopher ray as the president's
choice to head an embattled FBI in many
ways following the firing of Jim Comey
and amid that ongoing probe into
connections between Russia and the Trump
administration and the Trump campaign
now what we know is Christopher raisa
litigation attorney who actually comes
with the endorsement of New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie ray actually
served Christie in a personal capacity
during that so-called Bridgegate scandal
a few years ago we also know that chris
ray came in here to meet with President
Trump to interview for this job just
last Tuesday he was one of two remaining
candidates on a list that include many
names of people who had actually wood
drawn themselves looking at the scale
and scope of this job it will be a
challenging one for Ray or whomever
steps into this position given not only
the scrutiny on the FBI director right
now but the position that his boss or
direct boss Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is in as we've been reporting
the president has been frustrated
recently with the Justice Department and
his attorney general now having Chris
Rea report two sessions he's taking on a
big job at a time when there is
incredible scrutiny on the FBI and a lot
of pressure from the White House to try
to change the focus change the narrative
away from this ongoing questioning about
any kind of alleged contact between
Russia and the Trump team so at least
for today the president has changed the
focus and to what is next and not
exactly what happened when he fired FBI
director Comey who will be testifying on
Capitol Hill tomorrow I thought Margaret
the president was trying to focus on
infrastructure today
that is the agenda that is the agenda
and that is a supposed to be what all
the pomp and circumstance is about but I
guess president Trump knows his audience
if he's been watching the news shows he
knows what we've been talking about got
it Margaret thank you so much